[Applause]
little [ __ ] didn't get dealing with
uncle Joey here in training [ __ ] four
or five stars last night down at
Hollywood the cheaters I'm still [ __ ]
up I can't even open my eyes right
before mushrooms and stars tonight we
got a podcast at 8:00 what a funky think
you're dealing with
I've been training [ __ ] olympic-style
THC [ __ ] training and I'm hope you're
doing the same like I said it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you washed your [ __ ] you shaved yeah so
that was time you got to shake that
[ __ ] urn [ __ ] booked
Joey enough with the chitty-chat a spark
that soldier of a man of many Rufus we
got XJ 13 from perennial we get the
party started my head is all [ __ ] up I
washed my [ __ ] I already had a [ __ ]
smoothie my flaxseeds I'm ready to go to
jujitsu I gotta call people today I
gotta meet people at 4:30 I gotta
[ __ ] podcast at night who's better
than you [ __ ] your uncle Joey
we're always move them if you stop
moving you won't feel the [ __ ] breeze
you understand me
what can I tell you
[Applause]
the rest is up to you [ __ ]
I'm just a conduit of love you
understand now that's it I got big
things tonight big [ __ ] things
it's cloudy
you know people got happy but [ __ ]
Here I am front and center swinging dick
and giving our [ __ ] candy and I told
you [ __ ] I love reefer listen I
don't like cake Nilesh but a good bowl
of the morning have a nice breakfast
before a good [ __ ] book
cuz I'm ready I'm ready to [ __ ] it's
Wednesday you can't be laying down today
people start laying down for his when I
picked up this is when you picked up
their [ __ ] throwing board
we forget to get the only besides that
man I don't know what the [ __ ] to tell
you gotta go out there Joker
[ __ ] today you got it wasn't
there bring your knife you got to bring
the [ __ ] I mean you gotta bring
everything because you ain't losing you
ever have those days like today I'm not
losing if anything somebody's gonna
swallow my [ __ ] sword understand me
that's your attitude when you're leaving
that house who the [ __ ] on a sudden my
dick today huh that's your attitude
you're probably thinking about that
right I love my new app it tells me what
directions the sun's fly who gives a
[ __ ] flop the Sun flop over and [ __ ]
your grandmother don't worry about my
name here with you you know who's out
there going Hanahan compounded daily you
don't way bundle bah that's a problem he
won't stop drinking he gives a [ __ ] you
got a job to do that's it
these [ __ ] don't gonna get on
the train keep [ __ ] walking as people
will wait for a bus you'll never want to
get out today and I go no way what are
you gonna do be honest it [ __ ]
therapist you gotta keep smoking you
gotta keep doing [ __ ] jumping jacks
and you gotta go up and say you know
what I ain't stopping so somebody puts a
[ __ ] vampire joy what's what do you
mean listen this reification of [ __ ]
up places you know
I wanna pick up another [ __ ] deadly
batch of death today [ __ ] today's
the day it's big stocked update I got
some [ __ ] og death coming my way
today the one I do call last night he's
back from [ __ ] Morocco and that's it
you sit hang on what about dude - he
gonna be Joey teller at 8 o'clock or
coming live YouTube whatever the [ __ ] it
is then yeah how which every time you do
some stars we listen to music vo Barnes
coming down that's it good better than
[ __ ] you know buddy you got the world
by the balls and you're sitting there
playing it meanwhile it's time to set
the [ __ ] little bear free jack hey
you don't ball like a ship the door
people to see the light of history Baldy
in the mud to show you you do the same
[ __ ] every day take it a little even if
it starts with reefer if it this is what
it takes to get you on that house to
make it happen then [ __ ] it
why sit there looking like Madonna or
[ __ ] prime face
see how your assignment for the day get
my dick sucked eat some lunch get your
dick sucked right a little bit get your
dick sucked
come on man I have a mama do what you
need to do on Sunday and he's on the
clock it's the [ __ ] Mayan people get
a motorcycle all set I'm gonna [ __ ] a
bike again
it takes more a motorcycle a leather
jacket to be a [ __ ] bike then you
[ __ ] mob boss when I was a kid I grew
up with some [ __ ] Hells Angels repaid
blockburger on Kennedy Boulevard then
invite me and asked me if I wanted to
[ __ ] get high [ __ ] like that want to
give a shout-out to my main nephew Tammy
Holloway I'm del be spooky waterboxx it
Cleo my man Lea della Vegas Constantine
rain is at my hair no what the [ __ ] is
time East is somewhere in Hollywood
[ __ ] smoking by himself that [ __ ]
Savage and beside that day you walk by
one my god do you let her go
like I said you got your schedule for
the day the rest is on Pete
oh I love it
just remember [ __ ] reefer in the
morning gets my dick hard and besides
that that's it that's it in that said I
love you [ __ ] along my heart I
want you to go out there today and I'll
look over your shoulder love me you're
walking with a big big it when you walk
it along we have the biggest they're
gonna let us say something who's better
than you nobody in a way it's like will
you go with me and they wanna be with us
[ __ ] see you [ __ ] ten nine
eight o'clock in June I'm coming to
Omaha and Philadelphia oh [ __ ] Oh
stay black see you at 8 o'clock don't
take [ __ ] from nobody today they got all
[ __ ] stiff you [ __ ] nut sack oh
you can't have my man like being annoyed
about porosity do it before you see
Jeremiah Ezekiel come from that will
bother I love you [ __ ] stay
black